[Aplausos]
[Música]
no voy a sorprender a nadie pero en
términos económicos las últimas tres
décadas han estado dominadas sobre todo
por dos conceptos
íntimamente vinculados entre sí por
supuesto estoy hablando de uno la
globalización y dos la deslocalización
todos absolutamente todos conocemos y
seguramente además bastante bien estos
dos fenómenos económicos y políticos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
por un lado Durante los últimos 40-50
años las fronteras del mundo se han
diluido de repente las mercancías los
capitales y las personas se pusieron a
viajar frenéticamente a lo largo y ancho
de todo el mundo las restricciones cada
vez eran menos por otro lado las grandes
multinacionales trasladaron gran parte
de su producción habitualmente los
procesos menos complejos a países con
mano de obra más barata y regulaciones
más cómodas ahora a través de una enorme
interminable y complejísima cadena
logística los productos que llegan al
mercado por ejemplo un Smartphone suelen
estar hechos con piezas componentes y
tecnologías de un montón de países
distintos
Pero si hablamos de la globalización y
de la deslocalización tenemos que hablar
necesariamente de un país un país que ha
explotado esta nueva realidad económica
como ningún otro y estoy por supuesto
hablando de la conocida como la fábrica
del mundo la República popular China
y motivos No faltan cerca del 30% de
toda la producción industrial del
planeta tierra pasa precisamente por
este país china se ha convertido en una
gigantesca potencia económica Industrial
gracias a este sistema económico durante
años y años las multinacionales de todo
el mundo se han instalado en el gigante
asiático tanto para producir como para
intentar hacerse hueco en su descomunal
al mercado con casi 1400 millones de
consumidores potenciales sin embargo
stop un momento porque ahora este
proceso se está frenando en Seco las
tensiones comerciales entre China y
Estados Unidos no han parado de crecer
en los últimos años y la llegada de
trampa a la casa blanca marcó un antes y
un después
[Música]
en febrero del 2018 la potencia
norteamericana comenzó una guerra
comercial que supuso que para diciembre
del 2019 cerca de 250.000 millones de
bienes de producción china pasaron a
estar sujetos a un arancel del
25%. unos aranceles que ahora la
administración biden ha decidido
mantener al tiempo que ha introducido
nuevas restricciones al comercio
tecnológico con el gigante asiático
[Música]
las cosas van de mal en peor las
imágenes de estrechando lazos con
Vladimir Putin o las constantes amenazas
sobre Taiwán han sido algo así como la
gota que ha colmado el vaso las
tensiones en Taiwán obligan a las
multinacionales a replantearse el riesgo
de China queridos amigos amigas sí la
globalización hecha abajo muros
fronterizos pero ahora estos Están
volviendo a emerger y ni siquiera
hablamos únicamente de China Gracias a
la economía globalizada países como
Corea del Sur o Taiwán entre otras
muchos también se han convertido en
proveedores absolutamente claves para
occidente
[Música]
en el caso de Taiwán por ejemplo
Hablamos de una isla donde se producen
los semiconductores más avanzados del
planeta chips absolutamente necesarios
para las empresas tecnológicas y
militares de Estados Unidos desde Apple
hasta la login Martin porque por si no
lo sabíais Taiwán o mejor dicho la
industria de Chip Taiwán esa juega un
papel importante en la producción de
equipos como el f-35 Pero entonces qué
podría ocurrir si por ejemplo un buen
día Pekín decidiera bloquear Taiwán Y si
china finalmente decidiera invadir La
Isla qué ocurriría con las cadenas de
suministro y además si algo así se
produce o simplemente las tensiones
entre China y Estados Unidos siguen
creciendo como tendrían que reaccionar
las multinacionales qué pasaría con el
riesgo geopolítico o con simplemente el
riesgo reputacional deberían acaso
abandonar china se está pensando mucho
en las posibles alternativas hasta
llegar a Qué haremos en caso de que haya
una guerra debemos cerrar nuestras
operaciones en China Cómo podemos
mantener nuestro negocio y superar
posibles bloqueos George Wood director
de la cámara de comercio de la Unión
Europea en China Es evidente la invasión
rusa de Ucrania lo enviado todo ha sido
Por así decirlo todo una bomba de
relojería lo que antes se consideraba
impensable ahora se percibe como posible
e incluso como probable
ahora en medio de su primera gran crisis
de 1978 la china de empieza a ser un
país incómodo para los inversores y las
multinacionales y por eso aunque no
pueden abandonar semejante mercado cada
vez son más y más las compañías que se
están planteando seriamente trasladar
parte de su producción fuera de China y
de hecho desde el inicio de la guerra
comercial este país ha perdido cerca de
cuatro puntos en su cuota de Mercado en
las importaciones de Estados Unidos para
que os hagáis una idea esto supone cerca
de 117 mil millones de dólares y no solo
eso frente a la deslocalización
tradicional la de toda la vida ahora se
ha puesto de moda otro concepto el
niarsoring esto es deslocalizarse pero
cerca de casa a ser posible a países
vecinos el problema Pues precisamente la
falta de alternativas viables sin
embargo para las empresas
norteamericanas hay un país con mucha
mano de obra salarios relativamente
reducidos y una garantía total para los
suministros sabéis de qué país estoy
hablando exactamente 3 2 1 Exacto Por
supuesto estoy hablando de México
la década mexicana
pese a todos los problemas que no son
precisamente pocos como la violencia el
narcotráfico o la corrupción
generalizada Lo cierto es que la
economía mexicana ha mejorado mucho Y
esto no ha sido algo fortuito Todo
comenzó en 1965 cuando se puso en marcha
el conocido como programa de
industrialización de la frontera
[Música]
este plan permitía que empresas
extranjeras orientadas a la exportación
se instalaran en parques industriales
mexicanos y pudieran operar desde ellos
con ciertos beneficios por ejemplo no
tener que pagar aranceles para la
importación de suministros fueron las
llamadas maquilladoras el embrión del
potentísimo tejido Industrial que hoy
encontramos en México allí nació por
ejemplo La Apuesta mexicana por la
Industria Del automóvil que hoy genera
más de 2 millones de empleos que se dice
pronto De hecho hoy el superávit
comercial de la industria Automotriz Es
mayor que el excedente que México
obtiene por el comercio de petróleo el
turismo y las remesas fijaos
pero más allá del plan de 1965
encontramos otros dos momentos clave Los
Dos Grandes puntos de inflexión de la
economía mexicana que además fueron casi
consecutivos
[Música]
el primero de ellos tuvo lugar a
comienzos de la década de los 80 cuando
el país decidió dejar atrás el
proteccionismo y apostar por un nuevo
modelo económico desde entonces este
país se ha convertido en uno de los más
globalizados de todo el mundo ha firmado
acuerdos de libre comercio con más de 40
países precisamente uno de ellos y el
segundo gran punto de inflexión fue por
supuesto el acuerdo de libre comercio
con Estados Unidos y Canadá este acuerdo
entró en vigor en 1994 y desde entonces
las exportaciones mexicanas han pasado
de representar el 12% del pib al entorno
del 40 hoy México es un importantísimo
productor de automóviles piezas
aeroespaciales y dispositivos médicos
empresas como la General Motors Boeing
Bombardier Kia Lego rolls-royce la de
los motores de aviones entre otras
muchas ya tienen enormes factorías en
este país y ojo que hablamos Ni más ni
menos que del sexto mayor productor de
tecnología de todo el mundo y la tercera
economía que más inversión extranjera
recibe en el sector aeroespacial poca
broma fijaos cómo han cambiado las cosas
[Música]
por supuesto las relaciones con la
economía estadounidense son la gran
protagonista de toda esta historia para
que os hagáis una idea el comercio
bilateral entre Estados Unidos y México
ha crecido una tasa media anual de más
del 8% Durante los últimos 28 años y ojo
porque lejos de frenarse esta dinámica
parece cobrar cada vez más y más y más
velocidad en 2022 por ejemplo las
exportaciones mexicanas al norte de la
frontera se estima que crecieron cerca
de un 20% sí muchas veces en Estados
Unidos se habla de la frontera Sur como
una especie de gran problema sin embargo
siempre se olvida su característica más
importante de todas cada minuto un
millón de dólares de productos
comerciales atraviesa esta frontera en
un sentido u otro insisto cada minuto
hablamos de casi 1500 millones de
dólares diarios de locos
muchas grandes empresas de Estados
Unidos se instalan en México para hacer
algo muy similar a lo que otras hacen en
China esencialmente el esquema es el
siguiente los diseños y los componentes
más avanzados Los importan de Estados
Unidos y de países como Japón Taiwán o
Corea del Sur luego en México terminan
de dar forma al producto lo ensamblan y
más tarde lo exportan de vuelta al
vecino del Norte
esa es básicamente La idea inicial Claro
que luego con el paso del tiempo muchas
empresas comienzan a realizar también
actividades mucho más complejas y eso
explicaba porque este país es
precisamente el segundo gran proveedor
de los Estados Unidos tan solo por
detrás de China y ojo porque ni siquiera
está tan lejos Mientras que el peso de
china en las importaciones de Estados
Unidos se ha reducido del 27 al entorno
del 22%, el de México se ha mantenido
estable en el entorno del 16 17% En
otras palabras que se habla mucho de
China pero México es casi tan importante
para los Estados Unidos como el gigante
asiático sorprendidos pues queridos
amigos amigas echad el freno porque lo
mejor podría estar aún por llegar
recordáis lo que hemos dicho de la
crisis de la globalización y de la nueva
moda del nearsoning Pues bien aquí
México se lleva la palma
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para la industria de los Estados Unidos
este país tiene muchísimas ventajas por
ejemplo es una enorme fuente de mano de
obra relativamente joven y bien
preparada tiene fáciles conexiones por
carretera y ferrocarril un acceso
comercial privilegiado y para colmo los
costes laborales medios ya son más bajos
que la mismísima china sí sí me habéis
escuchado perfectamente más bajos que en
la mismísima china fijaos
además aparte de la frontera de Estados
Unidos México tiene también salida tanto
al océano Pacífico como al Océano
Atlántico esto quiere decir que tiene
una posición privilegiada ya que puede
importar fácilmente componentes de Asia
de Estados Unidos o de Europa al mismo
tiempo y aún más sabíais que México es
el octavo país del mundo que más
ingenieros gradúa cada año sabías que
enviar un contenedor de México a Nueva
York lleva menos de cinco días mientras
que enviarlo desde Hong Kong o Shanghai
puede suponer hasta 40 es decir en otras
palabras y si le damos una vuelta a
México parece con mucha diferencia el
destino predilecto para la producción de
las compañías norteamericanas ahora bien
Qué implicaciones puede tener realmente
la moda del para México realmente
podemos decir que ante toda una
oportunidad o no es más que uno de esos
conceptos que se ponen de moda pero que
a la hora de la verdad no valen para
nada
[Música]
pues queréis un dato en 2021 los
inversores estadounidenses pusieron ya
más dinero en México que en la propia
china además según estimaciones del
banco América si México Apuesta
decididamente por este proceso Se
exportaciones podrían crecer un 30%
Durante los próximos años hablamos de
más de 150.000 millones de dólares de
nuevas exportaciones cada año por
supuesto eso supondría millones de
empleos y mucha muchísima riqueza y
ahora están al alcance de la mano
chillan ha creado una enorme grieta de
la que ahora México puede aprovecharse
Claro que un momento porque
desgraciadamente no todo es tan bonito
México parece estar a las puertas de una
nueva era dorada si se hacen bien las
cosas podríamos llegar a hablar incluso
de la década mexicana ahora la economía
de este país podría fácilmente crecer
por encima del 5 o incluso el 6% cada
año sin embargo también es posible que
la oportunidad se termine perdiendo O al
menos no se le saque el máximo provecho
y sabéis que mucho ojo porque eso es
exactamente lo que podría ocurrir
atentos
[Aplausos]
con amlo hemos topado
a ver las ventajas de la economía
mexicana parecen muy claras sin embargo
luego a la hora de la verdad las cosas
no parecen carburar también O al menos
no tan bien como sería lógico esperar
por ejemplo desde que viera comienzo la
guerra comercial entre Estados Unidos y
China la cuota de Mercado de México en
las importaciones de Estados Unidos
apenas cambió la caída de China fue
capitalizada fundamentalmente por otros
países asiáticos fijaos la mayoría de
las ganancias han ido a asian India y
Corea al menos por ahora los datos de
penetración de las importaciones de
Estados Unidos no apoyan la opinión de
que en México ha sido un beneficiario
neto del New yorkshoring informe de vs y
no solo eso desde el 2015 la inversión
en capital fijo esto es en máquinas
fábricas edificios establecimientos
oficinas etcétera etcétera dejo de
crecer y desde el 2019 para colmo se ha
reducido además su economía en los
últimos años también ha sido una de las
menos dinámicas de todo América Latina
Así que digámoslo muy claro esto supone
un gran fracaso político
[Música]
el mayor impedimento para que México
desarrolle todo su potencial como
alternativa china puede ser precisamente
el propio México por ejemplo el
presidente actual es oscila la inversión
extranjera y de hecho una de sus
primeras decisiones cuando llegó al
poder fue cerrar Pro México una agencia
gubernamental dedicada a promover la
inversión extranjera en el país no la
reformó ni la puso deberes no la cerró
luego las infraestructuras tienen
también enormes carencias pero aún así
el gobierno Mira para otro lado y dedica
buena parte de la inversión pública a
proyectos de tan dudosa rentabilidad
como el tren Maya y por supuesto
titulares como estos no ayudan nada de
nada 12 de junio de 2022 México apunta a
las empresas privadas amenazando décadas
de crecimiento económico 14 de enero de
2023 El giro de México a la autocracia
debería preocupar a los Estados Unidos
creéis un ejemplo concreto pues fijaos
amlo tienen 13 Ceja y cejas recuperar el
control Estatal sobre los sectores del
petróleo el gas y la electricidad para
ello no ha dudado en cerrar centrales
eléctricas privadas con dudosos motivos
bloquear terminales de importación de
combustibles en los puertos suspender
las nuevas subastas de exploración de
hidrocarburos paralizar las nuevas
inversiones privadas en el sector
eléctrico o incluso sacar adelante una
ley que obliga la red eléctrica a dar
prioridad a la electricidad producida
por cc la eléctrica del estado A pesar
de que su energía es más costosa y mucho
más contaminante eso Por ejemplo hace
que la electricidad en México sea un 40%
más cara que los Estados Unidos lo que
supone una Clara desventaja para las
empresas industriales otro ejemplo pues
atentos México nacionaliza el litio en
el impulso del presidente populista para
extender el control Estatal esto amenaza
el único proyecto significativo de litio
que había en México qué queréis que os
diga son solo algunos ejemplos de lo que
es una dinámica demasiado habitual hablo
no le gustan las multinacionales ni la
inversión extranjera Así que se dedica a
poner palos en las ruedas
Hablamos de una actitud que hizo que
varios senadores de los Estados Unidos
llegaran a pedirle al presidente biden
que tomara medidas inmediatas contra lo
que consideraban una agresión al acuerdo
de libre comercio de Norteamérica El
problema es que todas estas políticas y
la enorme incertidumbre regulatoria que
está alimentando amlo puede hacer que el
país pierda una oportunidad histórica de
momento que el crecimiento sea débil o
que la inmigración de mexicanos a
Estados Unidos se haya acelerado por
primera vez en más de 10 años no parecen
buenos resultados
con todo quedémonos con la parte más
positiva México parece tenerlo casi todo
para convertirse en uno de los brazos
industriales y tecnológicos de las
economías occidentales
[Aplausos]
hoy por hoy los parques industriales del
Norte del país están a rebosar y cada
vez más empresas se preguntan si sus
próximas inversiones no tendrían que
dirigirse precisamente al país del
tequila los tacos los mariachis y el
Eterno verano si México hace las cosas
bien reduce la incertidumbre mejora sus
infraestructuras y favorece la inversión
extranjera la próxima década Podría
tener como gran protagonista mundial al
mayor país hispano de todo el planeta no
me digáis que no volaría pero llegados
hasta aquí turno para ti crees que
México aprovechará esta oportunidad será
esta la década mexicana qué crees que
tiene que hacer exactamente el gobierno
mexicano para impulsar todo este proceso
déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios
y hablamos debate ahora si este vídeo se
resultó interesante no olvidéis darle a
like y suscribiros a visualpolitik si es
que aún no lo habéis hecho una vez más
Muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]